there's anger and grief across the
occupied west bank after israeli forces
killed a senior commander of al-aqsa
mata's brigades a palestinian armed
group resisting israeli occupation
thousands of mourners filled the streets
of nablus where ibrahimovic was killed
some cities in the occupied west bank
have called for a general strike al-aqsa
marta's brigades say their response will
fit the crime ibrahim was known as the
lion of nablus his mother says there
will be many who will continue his
mission
they think they killed ibrahim but there
are hundreds of ibrahims there are
millions of ibrahims every palestinian
is ibrahim
the israeli military says it surrounded
ibrahim lucy's home and after an
exchange of gunfire used
shoulder-launched missiles against the
building two others were killed in the
operation more than 60 people were
reported injured john holman has mourner
from nablus
you can see that there's a crowd of
people young men who've come to the
house here in nablus in the occupied
west bank where ibrahim al-nabul
was killed by israeli forces actually up
above you can see the bullet holes in
the roof there was a fire fight that
lasted from five in the morning
to
three or four hours in which he was
eventually holed up in this building uh
and then killed just spoke to an
eyewitness that he said that he
eventually found the body just um just
next to where i'm
standing
so also
in this firefight
more than 60 people were injured and
ibrahim al-nabushi wasn't the only
person that died another member of the
group died here with him and also
another
young
member of the group which is the al-aqsa
martyrs brigade now israeli forces said
that they went after him because he had
fired at civilians and soldiers
especially those heading to joseph's
tomb which is a sacred site to jews and
muslims and christians which is quite
close to here here in nablus though
he is seen as a fighter that was uh
fighting against what people see here as
oppression
against the occupiers of the
of the occupied west bank and as such
his funeral procession here and the
mourning for him is being felt not just
in nablus but in other towns like hebron
and ramallah in which shops are also
shutting here in the occupied west bank
people in gaza are still mourning and
burying their dead in the wake of three
days of fighting between the
palestinian-islamic jihad group and
israel
on tuesday the death toll rose to 46
palestinians killed by israeli fire
15 of them were children and hundreds
more were injured a cease-fire agreement
was broken by egypt on monday